I just filmed this video and the
microphone didn't flippin work so I ate
a sandwich and here we are again hi
everyone my name is Tamra chambers and
this is Tamra's never seen take two and
today I'm watching bird emic I'm lightly
cosplaying the lead female character in
this movie throw a wig on anything and
it's a lot less fun my motto in life I
spent two weeks recently filming with
Brad Jones and Korey Goodwin and I told
them a bit about November and they were
like have you seen her Demick it's kind
of like a bird's knock off sort of deal
which I've seen bits and pieces of it
was maybe $10,000 which is fun I'm
hoping it's like a fun like a fun good
bad you know it's like a low-budget
cheesy thing hopefully it's fun please
let it be fun I need a fun movie because
I'm still sick and I'm hopped up on
medications let's just do it okay bye
[Music]
what would that Birdemic Chuck and
terror I love a low-budget film like
this and and I immediately went on and
looked up the director he does not think
that it's a bad film
he thinks it's like this really great
commentary on global warming and I love
that it makes it more endearing the
story is hilarious the effects are
hilarious the acting is yeah I hate
talking about acting especially like
lower budget movies especially
especially because I've been low budget
movies like you go on you you look up as
many reviews as you can find this has
kind of somewhat of a cult following so
I don't imagine they're still doing that
if anyone sees this it was part of the
project I had a really good time how can
you not enjoy a movie called Birdemic
where the birds only have two sounds one
being the loudest screeching car that
you've ever heard and two being a
literal wroom wroom wroom it opens up
and the credits are bonkers it's like
this very long extremely blurry shot a
lot of the shots in this movie are
really really blurry and it's this long
blurry shot out of somebody's front
window in a car and they're just driving
on this windy road and the font is
literally it's like an iMovie fun well
that's it's actually pop that I use
collide so I should cheddar there's a
lot of very weird things in this movie
but one of the weirdest things to me is
this sound one character will be talking
to another character is something back
and forth cutting back and forth between
their faces and every time it cuts back
and forth this sound completely jumps
like it's not fluid at all it's like
quiet like they use different Mike Smith
sound was so jarring and there were no
birds where is the bird it's called
Birdemic all we know about our female
lead
nately is that she's a fashion model who
doesn't live wherever this takes place
it's in a California coastal town but
she's here for a modeling audition what
she goes to the audition and she's
wearing like a long-sleeve shirt she's
doing poses like this like they're like
90s modeling then you find out that that
audition is for a Victoria's Secret
Top Model position nope congratulations
Natalie got the job then we have our
male lead character you guessed it his
name is rod both the worst and the best
name ever all we know about rod is that
he has a blue must the first like 30
minutes is just like him going to
different places in his blue mustang
then you see what he does for work and
he is a Salesman he's on the phone and
he's trying to reel in this big fish as
he calls it from work and he's like
alright let's just get down to it I'll
give you 50% off of the deal if we do
this thing right now
and then he goes great good doing
business with you Yahoo and his friend
comes in and is like did you just hook
that big fish and he's like yep for 1
million dollars
does that mean that the deal is for 2
million dollars you just lost 1 million
- it's real big letters I just wrote
where are the birds they're really
playing up the global warming aspect of
this though rod and his best friend are
outside playing basketball and out of
nowhere the best friend just goes whoa a
heat wave in winter crazy so you live in
a California coastal town there is no
winter there it doesn't matter if it's
December 31st
there's no winter in California coastal
towns okay you wear sweaters for fashion
I grew up there I lived there for 20
years I know
I know oh no special effect Birds okay
I'm on board these specific birds the
first ones that you see are these three
birds hovering above this weird bush and
they're all CGI and they have weird
shadows on them and they sound like
insects so I guess the birds have three
sounds they go to this bar and they're
dancing for the entirety of a song and
the whole time the dancing is just them
like in front of each other just go like
this she pulls a couple of these the
song it's about like hanging with your
family of weird and then they go to a
hotel to have sex and it's a very
awkward sex scene also they're both
adults with homes why are they going to
a hotel for this great you're setting up
for the next scene I suppose they don't
have to okay the sex scene she's in bra
and underwear and he's in like hole
pants and a belt and that's really all
you see is them kind of like kissing on
the bed and then they wake up and his
belt is still latched that's not how
that work we go from 30 seconds of
complete silence no background noise
I've been like waking up in bed after
having then the night of their lives
they're poor and then intense screeching
crazy screeching and a lot of rooms
happening are the rooms birds or are
those supposed to be like military
planes coming in taking out the birds
cuz every once in a while a bird will
explode in thin air and you're like it
see that bird just spontaneously combust
you don't see any planes so I have to
assume that the birds are rumen and that
they're just like randomly exploding out
of nowhere it's gotta be global warming
that's doing it they go to another hotel
room where there's another couple and
they team up with them they have a
broken-down van and guns
so coastal California town of them I
wrote this whole movie is a big global
warming activist movie and it can't be
doing any good for the cause I of course
believe in
warming but after this damage is cutting
it very important the truth
hold up this buzz and there's a guy
wearing an e ze shirt they save him then
he promptly dies so much screeching oh
there's also a ton of effort to show
that they're like survivalists and
they're gonna get through it they're
like we're gonna scavenge food and look
at there's a creek down there we're
gonna get some fresh water they go and
they find water three times and every
time they get lit they gallons of water
this hasn't even been a full day they're
in the forest
getting watered like you do and they run
into this like tree hugger character
their words not mine
who lives in the trees and wants to
protect the redwoods with the beautiful
trees and he goes on like a five-minute
rant about a hooker thing and then
they're leaving the forest and a forest
fire starts out of nowhere that's normal
Tuesday you know what I mean
they spend ten minutes catching a fish
again with the survivalist ship ten
minutes catching a fish cooking the fish
and then the kids decide they don't want
fish and so they don't eat the fish that
was such a waste all of these scenes are
such a waste they're not telling any
story here and the birds leave suddenly
as they came you don't see there's no
reason for them to leave they don't show
you anything any reason why they would
have left at all in the movie but you
know it must have been the global they
must have fixed global warming what a
way to end November wow just wow next
week I'm starting holiday movies I'm
very excited I haven't seen the Muppets
Christmas Carol like Christmas her
Cameron say
let me know if you have any ideas mostly
on Twitter's I don't I don't read the
comments because they're a deep dark
scary place where a global warming is at
its worst so I don't go damn it but let
me know on Twitter if you have any of
our holiday movies that aren't Christmas
related I would love to do those too
let me know thank you so much for
watching watch out for those birds
see you later
[Music]
[Applause]
you